venez nous rejoindre lens ça marche
le réalisateur et est très méchant c'est
vrai ouais avant tout méchant des
chiffres beaucoup
il frappe mentalement c'est un pervers
que j'aime beaucoup dans ces films c'est
que ils ont plusieurs couches il ya
plusieurs on peut l'aider plus sierra
leone lui on les voit une fois deux fois
trois fois c'est bien là dessus ça veut
dire quoi pour les acteurs ça veut dire
qu'on sait pas tellement ce qu'on fait
au moment où le fait est il faut il faut
lui faire confiance parce que vraiment
c'est pas ce qu'on fait en tant que
comédien et
on est perdu il nous paraît je pense
qu'il y fait exprès de nous perdre
c'est important de se perdre dans son
univers man ouest je pense qu'il faut
c'est parce que lui même
et même y fabrique des images qui sont
des images quasiment bas
ici on va dire enfin c'est un cinéma
dont on a très envie de parler mais en
même temps qui parle tellement c'est pas
très utile d'en parler parce que cinéma
d'image
voilà c'était votre personnage vous
allez me dire délicieusement atroce
atrocement délicieuse et je vais choisir
web allait elle est dans son rôle
moi je l'aimé la jouer ouais beaucoup
beaucoup
ouais c'est soit intéressant de jouer
quelqu'un qui est comme ça vraiment très
inscrit dans un champ sociologique en
fait c'est ça dont parle de film ça
assez simple le champ médiatique mais
c'est bien un petit peu bruno moulart
premier dans le prochain sur hbo
en tout cas je on se retrouvera mais me
prends mais en tant que non
professionnels cette fois merci beaucoup
à vous de merci infiniment nab